ein aufstieg genauso wie das brutale
ende der ausnahmekünstlerin
so kennt man amy winehouse kaum noch
liegt ihre karriere vorher noch kennt
sie keine drogen eskapaden aber die
stimme die hat sie schon von klein auf
der dokumentarfilm erinnert an das
mädchen hinter dem medienstar
frühjahr hatte sie bereits wo die
gefahren des erfolgs liegen
pikante ihre schwächen warum nur bekam
sie ihr leben nicht in den griff
vielleicht weil sie nie lernte mit rom
oder volk umzugehen der dokumentarfilm
zeigt dass sie schon als kind eine
rebellin war die sich von niemandem
etwas sagen ließ
einer der sich gut an amy winehouse
erinnert ist der musikjournalist
hanspeter künzler
er hat die soulsängerin kurz vor ihrem
durchbruch interviewt
das hat sich
das einzige das sie nie lang weilte war
die musik aber mit den höhenflügen und
abstürzen in ihrer karriere wusste sie
nicht umzugehen auch musste sie schon
früh mit inneren dämonen kämpfen
wenn man so jung berühmt wird hört man
auf erwachsen zu werden das ist typisch
für kinder stars wenn man mit 14 1 star
wird plötzlich millionen verdient wird
man auf erfahrungen aus dem normalen
leben zusammen
amy winehouse wurde zur ikone
sebastin und richtungsweisend
aber im film wird deutlich dass hinter
dem idol immer noch der störrische
teenager steckte
sie von ihren grün strophe wo er so
vollkommen kreis ausgesucht hat sie hat
alles gesagt dass von von gestern hat
sie in freundschaft und hat darum umso
verpennt über ihre knöchel sind ganz gut
ich will waren siemens war sie hasse ich
hautzustand mit
sie hat keinerlei sieht karl sich als
turbo
das machte sie zur leichten beute für
die medien die ihren zerfall genüsslich
ausschlachten
sie war polemisch liebte einen mann der
sie mit drogen abfüllte und sie blieb
unbelehrbar und weigerte sich einen
entzug zu machen ihr größter hit
entstand rehab
die tragik ihres scheiterns liegt hier
in den zeilen nicht in der heiteren
melodien
am 23 juli 2011 starb amy winehouse an
einer alkoholvergiftung
sie wurde 27 jahre alt
der dokumentarfilm setzt der musikerin
nicht nur ein denkmal sondern hat auch
eine pädagogische botschaft
wenn junge leute den film ansehen hoffe
ich dass sie erkennen dass nicht sein
heroin oder crack glamourös ist es ist
nicht lustig es ist langweilig und
furchtbar man sieht wie schnell das
leben dadurch beeinflusst wurde ich
denke es gibt viele aspekte warum sich
junge leute den film ansehen sollten
amy winehouse war auch einmal ein
glückliches mädchen voller musikalischer
leidenschaft
daran erinnert uns dieser dokumentarfilm
ihre skandalgeschichten werden
verblassen was bleibt ist ms
unverkennbares sorgt
wir sehen will was die schülerinnen und
schüler hier in winterthur mit der
rollenden theater werkstatt fahren